but that's like at what age at what age
did you know like you know you know like
fighting is like I remember I I asked
Tyson we had him at our event and Tyson
said when the first time he fought he
would fight scared he said I punched a
guy and I ducked because I was scared
and he says I saw him on the ground and
he says he brought his father back
and then his father fought me and he
says I did the same thing and I knocked
out a 30 year old man yeah he says
that's when I realized my punch really
had weight behind it when did you know
like fighting was your thing to do you
know not at that moment but I um I was
very sick as a kid so I was bullied a
lot I had a horrible skin disease I was
the leper in school that's what they
called me uh and needless to say uh you
know you start building an aggression
towards these bullish because it went on
a daily basis and then when I was 12
years old I saw a Bruce Lee movie
sneaked in started learning martial arts
took two years actually to convince my
parents but once I did it for two and a
half months I knocked the first bully
out uh the biggest one in my school
and that's when I realized wow this is
actually pretty easy because it was
Taekwondo what I did it was already
kicking but somehow I knocked on one
part she was out the problem was he
broke his nose in the process
so the police showed up and I confirmed
for my mom and dad that it was violence
and so they took me off martial law so
then I had to wait uh till I was 20 when
I moved out of the house and that's
immediately I started doing so 14 20
you're doing nothing oh no I am of
course I slipped in you know illegally
you know going to places watching
videotapes watching books and and katas
and you know so I was constantly busy
with it but I didn't have any people
teaching me but you would say you were
obsessed like it was an obsession of
yours immediately because you know once
you knock out a guy it feels really good
and then I went after all the bullies I
made a list with all the guys who had
bullied me in the past and I started
scratching off yeah yeah seriously yeah
and it was sad because some of them they
they literally said dude I don't even
remember I go
yeah this reminds me of two things
number one in the movie uh Billy Madison
and Steve Buscemi had a kill list of
whoever he was gonna you know whoever
bullied him if you've ever saw Billy
Madison
uh and then thank God that and then the
Kobe does Kobe said he had a very
similar list of guys that were ranked
higher than him in high school and he's
like all right this is my kill list 55
of them exactly because he was ranked
the 56th best high school athlete so one
by one by one he went after all of them
so like when you when you when when you
beat that bully up and you knocked him
out are these bullies kids that you went
to school with so did you go to school
or did you go to a park like where were
they they were much cool his name was
Chucky he was the biggest bully in my
school and he was bullying everybody so
came from a bad family has brought us in
jail for robbery this is a Netherlands
that was in the Netherlands yeah so and
there was one punch like I said it was
it was pretty easy and then I started
going after the bullish and it was all
the time like that it's just if I
connected when I connected the fight
would be over and I go oh did anybody
ever get you or no did you ever lose in
high school no I never lost on the
street ever never lost in your life in
my life yeah but boss you've never lost
a street fighter in your life no
yes I mean I never lost a street fight
in my life yes I should say that yeah
true nothing undefeated in the street so
so let me ask you like I guess the the
thing with you know how they say in Las
Vegas if you ever go to the bar don't
act too hard you know because you have
no clue you get the hell would you say
let me like you don't do that in Vegas
you don't do that insane you don't do
that in a lot of cities nowadays San
Diego you could do that to the wrong guy
but how many times have people not known
who you are because you have to know UFC
and MMA to know but if you know UFC MMA
everybody knows who you are and the
argument has won the greatest of all
time if not the greatest those are the
arguments you're in when it comes on to
a fighter you're on a lot of different
lists but how often have you gone to a
bar where a guy has no clue who you are
and they've tested you I know I've heard
the Brian orlocker story but like
stories like that do you have a lot of
those no it's you know I I used to and
then uh after the whole Swedish bar
fight story that I had with the bouncers
uh somehow I never I never had it
anymore but before that I would have
guys who would see me they would be
drunk of course and then I would just
called about it so it's like oh hey come
over here this guy said ass put him I
will give him my my card you know and
say hey tomorrow if you want to go you
know we can come to my gym and we can do
big gloves you know so nobody gets hurt
but you're not going to come and they
always said they were going to come and
nobody ever showed up and that didn't
happen a lot like four times so got it
so but but nobody really tested you
after they know who you were you're
saying that one bar fight they had no
clue who you were no they knew who I was
and they were known for it but they were
calling the the mafia bounces of us it
was a yugoslave him up and somehow they
were they did that to a lot of people
what year was this what year was this oh
it wasn't 99.98
and so accidentally they see you at the
bar and they know who you are told me
right away from the get-go to stay calm
when that went in started dancing with
the people guys ordering me a drink he
comes over the bouncers come over asking
me Hey listen uh you need to go you're
too busy you're bothering the customers
like Oh you mean the guy that's just
buying a drink for me but they pushed me
in between two doors in between doors it
started started pushing me one guy put a
finger in my eye I said I don't want any
trouble other eye knocked him out
and then the whole thing started like
five bottles just came yeah it was a big
one wow I actually have a very important
question for you
um so I believe like I in college I
played college football I was in I went
to Florida State I mean you talk about
beer steroids kegs parties there was two
types of guys there was a guy that was
looking for a girl to go home with at
the end of night or a guy that was just
looking for a fight at the end of the
night I was always of the former if you
know what I mean yeah but I would always
say it since then on anyone who went to
Florida stayed in the in the late 90s
early 2000s knows it was like you
couldn't avoid fist fights my question
in the lesson is I would at this point
in my life and I'm not looking for
fights but if I would get in a fight it
would not be with a random stranger it
would only be with someone that I know
that has done something to the point of
all right now we need to fight
disrespect yeah meaning I've seen so
many people would you say say something
you stepped on my toes yo bro why are
you looking at my girl like like it's
something hey buddy like your
interaction is maybe one second two
seconds
but now you're in a fist fight with this
person what advice would you have for
just people out there that are just
they've got a quick trigger and they're
looking for a fight next thing you know
they run into a bass route and at a bar
and their faces pummeled for the rest of
their life yeah for those types of
people it's don't pick a fight I have
students you know they look like kids
and there are they're 17 years old but
they won't mess you up you know you pick
a five of them and noon well with any
any lady from the UFC you are going to
lose it's it's that crazy you know and
nowadays like you said you don't know
who you're fighting and you can't tell
by their ex by their parents as well so
yeah don't don't do it because it can go
really wrong yeah especially if you have
no clue not only what their background
or what their training is but you don't
have you've never had any interaction
with this person why are you fighting a
person but I tell you nonsense are
probably more today than before probably
more today than before because even like
early 90s this thing wasn't you know uh
uh all over the you know you didn't
watch it every day it was boxing but it
wasn't UFC MMA hadn't yet blown up you
knew if you knew about it it's because
it was like a underground community that
knew this stuff so with all the
craziness taking place I believe future
looks bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of value payment it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got them in white we got
them in Black we got them in red our
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people weren't in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hats
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks bright toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]